I just want to notify everyone in
advance that I will be calling it a
vagina bag because in the UK Fanny means
vagina my name is Alicia and I'm a fanny
pack guru so if you're trying fanny
packs out for the first time the best
advice I can give you is to just exude
confidence with it there's no
inappropriate moment for a fanny if you
have the right look going on Danny packs
for life
I would prefer fanny packs or a thing
that were like socially acceptable I
actually wore funny facts Disneyland's
lost time I win and that was actually
the most amazing experience ever because
it was just so freeing my shoulders
always hurt from carrying a purse around
one of my friends is coming into town
this weekend so I'm gonna go to a fancy
dinner and a fanny pack for sure I'm
afraid that it's not gonna match with
all my clothes I'm really worried about
what people are gonna say I think
because it means you're looking at my
crotch
I like these sunglasses I'm gonna make
mine look like an emoji like an emoji
exploded all over there's actually quite
well themed minds of erotic yes simple
and I like the duck it's a bit
coordinated by accident
it looks like NASA stroke someone that
likes drugs
I got America all over my fanny so my
first experience was temperamental
because every time I walked it bounced
and made its way around to the front
even when I didn't require it to okay so
I'm moving today and my friend amber is
gonna come help me I am wearing my fanny
pack and she just knocked so let's go
I'm fading back I like it would you wear
one yeah I have what is not the most
fashionable and I already look nutso I
feel like it just makes it worse it's
making me realize how much I care about
other people's validation with what I'm
wearing right Griffith Park right now
we're on a hike this is the reason why
fanny packs is just because I have never
felt so comfortable today I'm going to
try and buy a car with my fanny pack on
I'm not gonna go to take me seriously
I've been validating the experience to
other people by saying it's an
experiment I haven't got any questions
about it today
but it's more annoying the novelty is
one huh I loved wearing a fanny pack
it was super convenient it was really
easy the only part was it looked
terrible with almost every outfit this
thing is too small it's like I could
barely fit anything in it it was
starting to fashion my outfits around
the fanny pack you just have to wear
like sporty clothes you even look like a
small child or a mum so today I've gone
with the 40 year old mother book and I'm
neither of those things but I felt I had
to dress that way I wasn't putting my
purse on the ground all the time not
sure how I feel being with this on I
guess it's better than putting a purse
on the ground if you care what people
think about you I wouldn't wear a fanny
pack